what kind of qualities are you looking
for in a relationship all is about you
know be honest always be honest seems
Bad Bunny might have found that in
Kendall Jenner a source tells ET that
relationship is getting more serious
it's really exciting our source says the
Puerto Rican rapper isn't only spending
time with the model but with the rest of
her family as well we're definitely a
close family like more than probably
normal and now Kitty sees a possible
future with him she's enjoying their
low-key relationship and feels excited
about where they're headed quote there's
certainly potential for long-term
longevity as they continue to spend more
time together it's not always easy but I
don't know I just kind of I like to keep
my private life pretty private so
I try my best but at the same time I
don't I don't like to let being seen out
in public with someone like affect my
everyday life yeah Kitty says she's all
about privacy but she's been anything
but with Bad Bunny since sparking dating
Rumors in February they've gone on Sushi
dates and romantic horseback rides and
they've checked out concerts Coachella
and most recently sad courtside at a Los
Angeles Lakers playoff game
foreign
s say it all our store says the two are
both always laughing and smiling
together I'm a good guy
I'm cute
The Source ads Bad Bunny loves that
Kenny's smart quick-witted and funny he
also likes that she is business oriented
and takes her job and fans seriously oh
my God just be cool all the time
speaking of jobs season three of the
Kardashians is about to kick off it all
comes back to protecting my piece with
Bad Bunny and Kendall getting more
serious will fans see their romance play
out on the Hulu reality series
likely no just sit from a really young
age I think both Kylie and I kind of
knew what we wanted to keep off the show
or what we wanted to keep to ourselves
and um yeah I think that it's kind of as
simple as that but there is this glimmer
of hope again our boundaries may change
one day depending on the situation but
yeah
[Music]